let's say we randomly assigned people with insomnia to one of two treatment
conditions. In one condition, participants received 20 milligrams of ambien, and
in the other condition patients received a placebo pill. The participants did
not know which they received. After taking their pills, the participants slept
in a sleep laboratory to help control for lurking variables. The next morning,
they rated their quality of sleep on a scale of 1 to 10, with 1 being very poor
quality of sleep and 10 being excellent. They reported this scale to a
psychologist who also did not know which treatment each person was assigned to.
It turns out that the people in the ambien group reported a higher quality of
sleep with an average of 8, whereas the people in the placebo group reported an
average of 5. What can we say is true about this scenario? Select all that
apply.